[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit lee frisieren guten abend
ihnen allen den sonntag sport im blick
hat auch heute wieder kristin otto sehr
gern gelernt und hier sind unsere themen
im überblick
die linke in schwierigen zeiten der neue
parteichef martin schirdewahn steht im
zdf-sommerinterview rede und antwort
[Musik]
außenministerin berbalk in japan in
nagasaki wird sie für eine welt ohne
atomwaffen und
siebter sieg nur milden für novak
djokovic der serbe holt damit seinen
insgesamt 21
grand-slam-titel
obwohl kriegsbedingt
lebenshaltungskosten sprunghaft steigen
was vor allem geringverdiener hart
trifft kann die linkspartei die dieses
klientel besonders adressiert davon
nicht profitieren es gibt interne
probleme es gibt diese wahlergebnisse
was der neue parteichef schirdewahn
jetzt tun will und wie seine antworten
auf die krisen derzeit lauten hat er im
zdf-sommerinterview gesagt daniel
pontzen
waffenlieferungen in die ukraine lehnt
schilde waren weiter ab trotz der sehr
persönlichen erfahrungen dass sein
großvater einst von us panzertruppen
gerettet wurde von meinem großvater mit
dem ich noch sehr intensiven kontakt
hatte als er noch lebte mit dem ich
teile auch meines lebens verbracht
teilweise jahre meines lebens habe ich
intensive diskussionen geführt ich bin
gar kein radikaler pazifist an der
stelle aber ich sehe sowie 40 prozent
der deutschen bevölkerung die gefahr
einer massiven eskalation dieses krieges
mit blick auf den drohenden
energieengpass in deutschland lehnt er
eine nutzung von nord stream zwei abdi
hat die jüngste klima ausschuss
vorsitzende der linken klaus ernst
erwogen er hatte sich korrigiert noch in
der öffentlichkeit an dieser stelle oder
er muss die frage nach energiesicherheit
aufwerfen als vorsitzender dieses
ausschusses das wird er in der
gesellschaft breit diskutiert welche
folgen hätte zum beispiel an einen öl im
waage für die region in schwedt und die
bundesregierung schuld noch immer einen
garantie plan für die dort beschäftigten
bezogen auf seine partei erwarte er dass
künftig alle gemeinsam entwickelten
positionen auch gemeinsam nach außen
vertreten würden also auch von sahra
wagenknecht die die wahl des neuen duos
scharf kritisiert hatte na ja das ist
natürlich auch eine stilfrage wie man
mit demokratischen eines parteitages
umgeht das muss jede und jeder für sich
entscheiden aber es geht ja nicht um
bruch es geht um eine gute
zusammenarbeit derjenigen die
verantwortung in der partei tragen er
und seine ko chefin wissler seien
gewillt mit der fraktion künftig
intensiv und gut zusammenzuarbeiten in
den zurückliegenden ersten zwei wochen
aber man das auch schon getan
das komplette zdf sommerinterview mit
martin schavan sehen sie dann direkt im
anschluss hier an uns oder auch in der
zdf- heute- app sollte energie knapper
und noch teurer werden will
verbraucherschutz ministerin lemke
kunden davor schützen dass ihnen strom
und gas abgestellt wird sollten sie ihre
rechnungen nicht mehr zahlen können im
krisenfall müsse man auch über ein
weiteres hilfspaket entscheiden sagte
sie der bild am sonntag
erleichtert ist die bundesregierung dass
kanada die ausfuhr einer reparierten
turbine genehmigt hat die für die
gaspipeline nord stream eins bestimmt
ist russland hat ja die erdgas zuvor
durch nord stream 1 seit wochen
gedrosselt unter anderem mit der
begründung dass genau diese turbine
fehle morgen soll die pipeline wegen
wartungsarbeiten
voraussichtlich für zehn tage ganz
abgeschaltet werden jetzt zum
kriegsgeschehen in die ukraine da gab es
weiterhin angriffe der russischen
streitkräfte im osten des landes im ort
jessica in der region donetsk wurde ein
wohnhaus getroffen dabei sind laut
ukrainischen angaben mindestens 15
menschen getötet worden zahlreiche
weitere wurden verletzt rettungskräfte
suchten unter den trümmern nach
verschütteten
intensive tage für außenministerin
annalena baerbock nach bali und palau
ging es weiter nach japan eine
gratwanderung und kein einfacher termin
nach dem attentat auf ex-premier shinzo
abe und heutigen oberhauswahlen im
inselstaat besuchte sie nagasaki und war
dort für eine welt ohne atomwaffen ulf
röller berichtet
in europa ist krieg nicht nur für
aussenministerin baerbock fühlen sich da
die schrecken der vergangenheit
besonders bedrohlich an l v3 morgens
explodierte die atombombe über nagasaki
es starben sofort etwa 22.000 menschen
wieder geht die angst vor allem
weltkrieg um der box appell wird
ungehört bleiben deswegen ist nagasaki
genauso wie hiroshima für uns auch heute
jahrzehnte danach ein mahnmal dafür dass
wir alle gemeinsam daran arbeiten müssen
an einer welt ohne atomwaffen
auch wenn wir davon sehr weit entfernt
sind die ministerin wollte das
automuseum in nagasaki besuchen und sie
wollte herrn tanaka treffen er überlebte
seine familie starb an den folgen der
atomstrahlung er hat eine botschaft die
die politik nie erfüllen konnte
friede schaffe man nicht mit gewalt
erklärt herr tanaka nur mit
verhandlungen und diplomatie
der burg reist in ein land das kräftig
aufrüstet auch japan erlebt eine
zeitenwende russlands und chinas macht
streben bedroht die region
die mehrheit der bevölkerung wolle das
militär stärken um das land besser
verteidigen zu können japan rücke von
der pazifistischen ausrichtung ab
nein hieß damals die atombombe die
ministerin wird klein davor die heutigen
sind viel tödlicher und es gibt viel
mehr davon
seit monaten fehlen benzin strom medizin
und andere lebenswichtige güter sri
lanka rebelliert infolge der schlimmsten
wirtschaftskrise seit der unabhängigkeit
1948 der präsident kündigte seinen
rücktritt an protestler stürmten gestern
seine residenz in der hauptstadt colombo
spielten sich erst chaotische dann teils
surreale szenen ab über die vergangenen
48 stunden luton linus die erste ruhe
nach dem sturm auf den präsidentenpalast
bemerkenswert friedlich nach monaten oft
blutiger proteste wollen sie den luxus
hier mal selbst erleben
ich will sehen was sie mit unserem
steuergeld gemacht haben ich bin teil
der protestbewegung politiker sollten
verstehen wie groß die macht des volkes
ist
sie wollen vorerst im palast bleiben in
besetzt halten bis präsident rajapakse
wirklich abgetreten ist
mehr als 100.000 menschen waren gestern
auf columbus straßenprotest gegen die
bisher schlimmste wirtschaftskrise des
landes mit wasserwerfern warnschüssen
und tränengas versuchte die polizei die
menge aufzuhalten am ende vergeblich
alle macht gehört dem volk das war es
jetzt
in letzter minute gelingt dem
präsidenten die flucht auf ein
marineschiff für kommenden mittwoch
kündigte rajapakse seinen rücktritt an
er und sein bruder regieren sri lanka
seit 2005 wie eine familiendynastie
sri lanka scheint an einem wendepunkt
wie auch die vielen religionen und
ethnien die sich so lange erbittert
bekämpft haben
wir haben uns jetzt versammelt wie eine
familie und feiern die wahre freiheit
eine hoffnung die viele beseelt auch die
picknick gäste heute auf dem rasen des
präsidentenpalasts
der süden europas ächzt unter hohen
temperaturen und großer trockenheit eine
folge sind erneut heftige waldbrände in
portugal ist das gebiet zwischen porto
und lissabon betroffen die feuerwehr ist
mit etwa 2200 kräften und
löschflugzeugen im einsatz starker wind
fachte die flammen immer wieder an auf
der kroatischen halbinsel istrien hat
ein feuer 40 hektar land verwüstet teile
der stadt pula waren zeitweise ohne
strom
wir sind jetzt beim sport christin wie
jeden sonntag einiges los richtig
einfach es war viel los sogar fangen wir
an mit der formel 1 ferrari-pilot
charlie claire hat den großen preis von
österreich in spielberg gewonnen vor
weltmeister max verstappen und rekord
champion lewis hamilton mann des tages
ist aber mit schumacher mit mutigen
überholmanövern wie hier ein kevin
magnussen hat er sich das redlich
verdienen rang sechs und gewählter
fahrer des tages
zeigen hoffentlich dann auch in der
zukunft noch mehreren haben wir so viele
punkte sammeln können max deppen gewinn
zwar den staat muss sich aber danach dem
stärkeren ferrari von charlie klar
geschlagen geben aufregung kurz vor
schluss carlos sainz und steigt in
letzter sekunde unverletzt seinem wegen
motorschadens brennenden ferrari
seit 2013 auf dem centre court des
heiligen rasen ungeschlagen nun hat der
serbe novak djokovic zum vierten mal
nacheinander wimbledon gewonnen diesmal
gegen den australier nick piräus in vier
sätzen
novak djokovic könig in seinem
englischen garten der serbe gewinnt zum
siebten mal auf wimbledons rasen auch
weil sich eine kirche aus australien mit
seiner verbalen rebellion oftmals selbst
außer gefecht setzt nach verlorenem
ersten satz kämpfte sich djokovic in die
partie zurück und
nutzt im tiebreak des vierten satzes
seinen dritten matchball sein 21
grand-slam-titel ein ganz besonderer
es war immer und wird immer mein herzens
turnier sein die inspiration für mich
warum ich tennis spiele
der siegerpokal aus den händen von
herzogin kate mal wieder eine art
krönung für novak djokovic
und toller erfolg für eine junge
deutsche ruderin mit einem überragenden
schlussspurt gewann die 20 jährige
alexandra pfister das eine rennen beim
weltcup-finale auf dem traditionsreichen
rotsee in luzern
der einzige sieg für die drv flotte denn
der deutschland achter wurde dritter
soviel dankeschön christin wir haben zum
schluss noch die wetteraussichten und
die gehen so morgen in einem streifen
von der nordsee bis zum bayerischen wald
viele wolken aber kaum regen sonst oft
sonnig die temperatur steigt auf 18 bis
23 im südwesten bis auf 28 grad
extreme trockenheit und hitze ein
schwerpunkt im heute journal um 21.45
mit marietta slomka für sie noch einen
entspannten sonntagabend und hier folgt
jetzt wie angekündigt das zdf
sommerinterview mit linken parteichef
martin schönwandt bis morgen
[Musik]